giampiero mi metti un surfista sui
capelli che fa surf perfetto così
aggiungi un po di effetto sonoro di onde
grazie non so se ve lo ricordate i
ragazzi ma siamo tornati oggi suam per
sony ricordate a fermare o no no non ho
risolto prima li ci sono molto prima di
se ci sono molto prima perché devo
morire dice che adesso c'era un altro
che si chiama humphery sonic per la mia
gioia
siccome oggi siamo diventati un canale
fremiti friendly perché nel 2019
dobbiamo essere dobbiamo andare incontro
alle famiglie e quindi non ci saranno
parlarci questo non potrò incavolarvi
c'è il massimo che posso fare quando
vorrei dire una cosa veramente brutta
nei confronti di del demonio di
qualsiasi altra persona io e sbatterò
fortissimo sulla mia tastiera perché
tanto youtube non lo rileva come non se
mi difende ok bene perché rompere
tastiere una cosa che le famiglie
possono vedere cominciamo sonic unfair
game fair l'hanno messo addirittura
sotto la scritta sonic facciamo vedere
che un gioco brutto va bene non c'è
audio e questa cosa mi disturba sono già
morto perché senza non ci puoi andare
tutto a posto tutto a posto fa vj per le
famiglie fa vj per le famiglie è tutto
tranquillo guardalo o inizio tranquillo
ragazzi va bene tutto va bene tutto
l'importante è mantenere la calma nella
vita io ve lo insegno fa vige vi insegna
oggi perché vi insegna a finire le cose
con l'api totale calma allora devo
capire un attimo una cosa come mai sto
gioco non ci all'audio ce l'ha sempre
avuto l'audi what happened
perché questo gioco non possiede audio
what's the problem my friends what's the
problem molto bene molto bene una sega
però non importa se però che si può dire
perché è un attrezzo
no signori dobbiamo capire non c'è
l'audio ci sono i check point in questo
gioco ci sono i check point immagini no
perché c'è un problema di fondo non ci
riesco ad arrivare in questi punti che
devo fare qua o no
l'unica cosa di audio che ho sentito
all'inizio del video ottimo bene siamo
partiti bene per il prossimo ragazzi non
so quanti livelli ci sono
questa cosa potrebbe essere un problema
perché potrei andare avanti all'infinito
calmati
ok potrà andare avanti alle viti o
ragazzi non so quanto quanti livelli ci
siano non ne ho la minima idea cosa devo
fare per spiega mano di melo
cosa devo fare lo saltare su robben
visibili cos'è a come faccio come come
dovrei sapere dove finire spiegami
perfetto poi era successo a naro
l'ocarina va bene
12 no no allora sei fermi 12
perfetto non lo so e youth non ci credo
non ci credo ho fatto le robe
incredibili non ci arriverò mai più li
ho fatto dei rom assurde ci sono andato
intuito nelle cose non so come che non
ce la farò veramente mai più nella vita
ok signori signori ce l'ho fatto
incredibile livello 3
sono stato bravissimo molto bene molto
bene sta lavorando marando morando un
porca vacca porca orca esempio animale
tami via perché non è difficilissimo
fare sta parterà che è allora fai e va
beh ma allora dei cd decidi tu
capiamoci 123 fermati modi sotto tutte e
due
ok mi sono morto io muoio
no ho sbagliato picchiato la start pirla
cioè vabbè mi ci metto pure io contro me
stesso ma dai non c'è niente qua ok
perfetto
io credo che la vita né con alcune
persone sia ingiusta 123 fetta perché
perché è così difficile ma non me lo
ricordavo così vi giuro
se la sono studiata per farti salire il
calendario c'è incredibile incredibile è
bello sto f unico effetto sonoro unfair
marble cos'è un mio dio eva ben tre
credo che stiamo andando un po oltre il
mio normale pensiero di gioco però va
beh penso che queste spina è invece non
erano spine veramente strano ma perché
tutto l'opposto di quello che pensi bene
quella era una spina io vi giuro che
vado a trovare il creatore di questo
gioco lo infilo nella lava quella stessa
che lui ha messo in questo livello ve lo
giuro perfetto che anche quel quel cubo
non era un cubo e ce l'ho fatta proprio
perché ci avevo pensato stavolta sono
stato un genio da serie se adesso
muoiono non riesco a ripartire per tutto
il video giusto così
vediamo punto ci devo rimettere a fare
questa cosa ma io sono pro curioso
guardalo ancora lui
cr7 lo sto facendo
giusto così doveva morto prima non mi
ricordo però prova a saltare anno è
finito afferma board 24 ora sto gioco è
possibile 76 morti comunque un signore
risultato portiamo i signori risultati a
casa vai molto bene quanto quello che ho
chiesto per incontrare non è un vero
cubo quanto ci fate da 1 a 100
e invece lo è e invece lo è
e invece e invece te lo prendi qua
incredibile per ora devo andare a caso
tipo faccio un salto chilometrico
perfetto non avevo idea di quale potesse
essere punto giusto e che il problema
questo live in certi punti fai veramente
h ovaia caso vai a caso non è possibile
peccato proprio filippo c'ero io l'ho
prima l'ho fatto per caso e adesso non
riesco più a 12
questo qua e pinto che di qua ca di qua
molto bene
cadi molto vila narciso salito cavalca
difficilissimo ragazzi ce la posso fare
ce la posso fare non sento let's golf
ce l'ho fatta ce l'ha fatta ce la feci
perché sono voluto andare lì sopra per
forza perché perché la mia vita mi ha
chiesto questo quando non era necessario
chiederlo perché sono successe cose ma
non fa niente
ma basta quanti livelli sono a quanti
quanti livelli mi fa fare
quanto dura sto gioco mai infatti no
vabbè regala seri ma troppo tempo ma dai
ma dai ma vai ma figurati
ma a quanto tempo sul serio rick sto
facendo cose veramente ragazzino pensavo
pensavo a definirlo due livelli fa dura
tantissimo più di quanto pensassi molto
bene ha detto lo infili quello molto
bene ok lo vedo lo vedo lo vedo lo vedo
lo vedo lo vedo non lo prendo per oro lo
vedo non so se vi interessa 95 morti
dopo 500 toni arrivo io 500 morti finito
finals o mariga ma quanto allora 95
morti voglio controllare giuro quanto
avevo fatto quando ho giocato nel fair
sonic tipo cinque anni fa al controllo
204 morti non mi possono riascoltare
neve quito per questa fosse una cosa che
sapete 204 fare meglio di 204 morti no
no no no no no ehi ehi bello lezzi o ma
che sta ed io no no no al crociato chi
cresce la famiglia cosa dici no ma serio
no rega marega
[Musica]
[Applauso]
david o signori sono riuscito alla vita
a ritornare quando un ammontare di morti
che conta 20 cioè incredibile sono
uscito a perché solo venti volte let's
golf
final zon finale fi nalmente dire dopo
due volte che mi sono fatto il gioco
[Musica]